[Music]
this morning on the dish opening a
restaurant is a big achievement creating
a whole new cuisine is another deal
that's what chef trong nguyen did at
houston's crawfish and noodles where he
blends the crabs and crawfish of cajun
country with the southeast asian spices
and cooking techniques that he was
raised with creating a flavor sensation
that's captivated diners while making a
truly global impact
janet chamlion has his story
a walk through the busy kitchen of chef
trung win is to find him wildly
outnumbered
by crustaceans of the gulf
hundreds of fresh crawfish and crab
filled the kitchen
but it's never enough
they always sell out at houston's
crawfish and noodles a modest strip mall
restaurant that has more accolades in
some of the country's finest dining
spots
including the most coveted of all a
james beard nomination for best chef
texas in 2020. quite a payoff for a guy
who spent 30 years in the casino
industry talk about a bet with no formal
training and a love for food he wagered
his life savings on opening a restaurant
you left a really good job to do this
very much yes it's something in me
telling me that you know
win or lose it's a gambler of life was
it a gamble of passion yes also
chef winn is credited as one of the
creators of what's become known as viet
cajun cuisine
this is back in the refugee camp
influenced by his family's cooking as a
child in vietnam before he immigrated to
the u.s it's a mix of southeast asia and
the good old american south
the cajun part is whole boiled crawfish
the vietnamese influence a soupy soak of
butter and garlic
these are like mini lobsters
that's all we do hand-picked that's
everything like this this side this
isn't your traditional crawfish boil for
one the secret blend of spices aren't
added in until after the mud bugs are
out of the water
okay now we put the flavor sauce in okay
that's garlic that's butter and garlic
and garlic
the imported butter imported butter
let me get a little bit more seasoning
in there
the first one is to lightly mix it now
now it's seasoning yes
[Music]
okay
actually yeah you got your hips going in
there this is how it's supposed to be
done
how is it different from a crawfish boil
in my backyard when you open it up yeah
you will see a big chunk of meat
still crunchy very very crunchy and
never yet never overcooked
so that is the big difference
it may be his signature dish but it's
only one of his creations
how do you create it do you just there's
is there a family recipe is it trial and
error like what is it for you
it's just food come in my mind naturally
so when i thought of something that i
like to eat i normally think of how
to put them together chef win says he
likes to experiment putting his own
stamp on dishes like stir-fry noodles
chicken wings spiced crab claws and a v
cajun lobster his favorite dish is
always his most recent creation
currently a v cajun salt and pepper
dungeness crab
that's a chunk of meat right there
okay and then you suck the sauce from
the outside
got a little bit of everything it's a
little salty and sweet
yes it's like a blend
it's a blend of spices
as any crawfish enthusiast knows there
is a proper way to eat a mud bug
i've had a fair share of the southern
delicacies but my technique needed
improvement so you hold a crawfish like
this
you kind of wreck it out
isn't it pull and turn yeah one time so
that's how you suck the head
you see all juicy and seasoning
kicking in
yeah
a little spicy a little
and a little messy
don't wear white
corey vins
vin is in the front of the hell cory the
back of the house to help me out
my wife here take care all the paperwork
and also help to prep to uh when we're
busy
so kind of a family business
chef wynn working alongside his son in
the kitchen even his mom helps
when we work in the kitchen we like the
machine
i mean the front run like crazy the back
is like
rolling business sank during the
pandemic like restaurants everywhere but
customers are back the loyal houston
area crowd and a never-ending flow of
tourists some come right from the
airport
customer is like our friend and family
they're very supportive it's now been
more than a decade since trongwind made
that wager to leave gambling and bet on
himself
you have no regrets from leaving the
casino industry
no sometimes i look back and say well
back then i only went suit time get
pretty walk away you know walk around
talk to people shake hands sit in the
night restaurant dining
with all the vip
but now i carry every single disc out of
the table to show it to the customer
but i'm very proud of it because that's
what we made that's what i made
so i'm very proud
for cbs this morning saturday i'm janet
chamleon in houston
he could have the best of both worlds by
opening a crawfish and noodles inside a
casino
there you go that's right
i want to see janet get her hips in that
like like when this is really like janet
shaking it what a great
sport did a great job well with the
crawfish wearing white
and i'll that's and i'll take all the
crawfish you don't want
they are yours they are your stuff
thanks janet